in the markets of Taiwan's capital city
Taipei you can find seemingly every
creature and it's not just choice meat
that's for sale but nearly every other
animal part as well the Chinese
sometimes complain their countrymen will
eat anything
very little is taboo and if there's one
Taiwanese gourmet who can turn the most
exotic fare into a delicacy fit for an
emperor it is chef ping Chang Cho mr.
Cho may be Taiwan's most highly
respected chef and tonight he will host
a very unusual dinner for some very
special guests including several of
Taiwan's
top food critics the dish she's chosen
to prepare is so taboo it may be one of
the few things many Chinese refuse to
eat the penis of the bull so this was
freshly killed today yes it was killed
this morning this is one entree that
challenges the diners and the chef's
alike if not prepared well the meat is
sinewy and tough and inside is the Bulls
urinary tract you have to cut it open
and wash it clean if you don't then
you'll have the taste of urine in your
food could this really be a meal prized
for centuries by Chinese emperors
traditionally it was considered a potent
aphrodisiac the Chinese version of
viagra for help with his recipe chef Joe
is turning to his friend dr. Zhen nearly
a specialist in Chinese medicine dr. Lee
knows exactly what combination of herbs
to prescribe to compliment
is bull penis more effective than viagra
oh yes as soon as it hits the tongue the
bull penis jump-starts the brain and
enhances sexual desire I guarantee we're
going to make them very happy
chef's show leaves the herbs to steep in
one pot while he stews the meat in
another it will take four hours to cook
for the Chinese a chef is like a doctor
and every meal is considered preventive
medicine here nearly every item is
believed to have a specific effect on
the body the Chinese believe that what
you eat is what you treat so if you eat
a pig's brain then you will treat a
human's brain likewise even a boy's
penis is thought to increase blood flow
to the genitals and boost a man's
stamina for sex people don't eat these
things every day you just couldn't take
it in his kitchen in Taiwan
chef Chow is finishing four hours of
work and he's ready to welcome his
guests among them are the leaders of
Taiwan's premier keulen area
associations men and women who can make
or break a chef's reputation even for
these experts this meal will be a rare
treat most of them have never eaten bull
penis before still no one wants to be
the first to dig in even in Taiwan there
are food taboos that can make
connoisseurs hesitate it's a little
scary but soon the verdict is end it's
just like eating a piece of beef with
tendons that is why chef Cho is so great
he was able to serve bull penises in
such a way that you can't tell which
part of the penis you're eating it's
high praise with his power to transform
the taboo into the tantalizing chef Cho
may win new converts to this ancient
delicacy diners who may seek it out not
just for its romantic and medicinal
effects but also for its taste